i
my day job is building open source tools
for the federal government with a group
called 18f
uh but this is a side project that i did
where i wanted to
i'm interested in
playing with gesture
and when most people say gesture and
think of think of mobile you know they
interpret it as
kind of interactions on that 2d surface
right of a swipe or a pinch or something
like that
but that's not really taking advantage
of
the device and the fact that it's not
attached to anything it doesn't have to
be like laying flat on a desk or
anything like that
um
so i think matt may have over hyped my
uh demo but
i didn't tell much because it really
only knows one thing
but uh
the first thing i wanted to you know try
to play with was
okay what if i could have a
you know some sort of interface where
i'm actually using my
mobile device using my phone to control
something on my screen and actually
treating
treating that mobile device like a
controller
so
i stole a
um
a model viewer in
3js
that
takes an stl file which is a format
that's common for 3d printing and other
sort of
3d 3d modeling sorts of uses and i'm
rendering it you know on the screen
that's basically their demo straight out
of the box
what i added in was a mobile view
so i visit a slightly different
page from my mobile device and now i'm
actually
able to control
using the gyroscope
and
they're kind of small but there's a
couple of uh arrows on there where i can
actually move the
thing around the screen and control zoom
and even works with multi-touch
it's a little jittery on this wi-fi but
on a local network it's usually pretty
good so
yeah so that was like pretty fun and it
actually turned
it actually ended up like touching a lot
of things that i didn't expect it to
um
in the sense that there's
3js and
you know canvas of the 3d rendering
context on this on this viewer page
so it's able to load a model and i have
a few
arbitrary models uh
in there but it can accept any stl file
and
so there's this rendering piece which
you know loads the stl file
converts it into a mesh throws it on
this canvas
then there's the
controller piece so this is a different
page being served from the same server
and using
gyroscope uh
events so
mobile devices give you
uh on orientation change events and so
you get you know something fired every
20 or 30 milliseconds or something like
that really quickly
um saying okay the device is in this
orientation the devices in this
orientation so then
using
node and socket io to actually transmit
that information from the mobile device
to
the viewer
any questions i can like kind of walk
through the code but that's that's
really that's really it is
uh
just just kind of getting this
connection working um any questions
where i can keep going yeah what's next
where did you go from here uh well i
don't have any like million dollar ideas
but if you do like let me know um
yeah i wanna play more with um
play more with these these sort of
interfaces where you know the phone is
not just like assumed flat yeah um
yeah i don't know i had an idea for like
a bop it kind of game or something like
that on you know the mobile device where
you shake it or you know something where
you're actually like
interacting with the environment around
you if anyone's ever played space team i
really like that kind of in person
uh
interaction uh you know actually using
the phones in the
you know in this sort of non-traditional
way so i don't really have anywhere that
i want to go with this necessarily uh
the code is open source and i'll show
the link at the end but
um yeah i was kind of pleased as a proof
of concept
um what about multiple devices uh it
theoretically could work so
i have um
it'll be really hard to see up here but
um i have
you know chrome
here with device emulation
i don't know why it's all jittery but
you know i'm not able to not only
control it from there but able to you
know control it from this device as well
you know theoretically you could have
you know multiple models you could like
have jousting or something like that uh
that could be a fun fun way to go that i
don't know i really thought about it but
uh theoretically it would be pretty easy
to extend
so yeah the um
so something i
i took an animation class in college you
know like a computer graphics class and
did not do well but i was
sort of forced to go through a lot of
these things uh with 3js and
one thing i learned about was
uh gimbal lock
so if anyone i'm probably going to
butcher the explanation but essentially
if you think about a device or an object
having
you know three degrees of rotation right
like pitch yawn roll
if you simply express
the rotation like from the phone
applied to that object
with those three degrees of rotation uh
which is called boiler angles
i'm pretty sure that's the same thing
um you run into something called gimbal
lock so if you do like what i just did
and try to do a 360 you'd see it flip
halfway through you've probably seen
this in like crappy video games um
but
the reason is has something to do with
um
and i have pictures i can't really
explain them but
but basically you have these three
three degrees of rotation and when
the
one two degrees of rotation align uh
you're then not able to like rotate so
it has to flip to like get past it
it's my hand wavy explanation
but uh so
i end up using something called
quaternions which
um i believe is represented more as a
vector with rotation
and so that doesn't have the
gimbal lock problem which made the like
flipping smooth
uh
like pong in a circle and so
that was another kind of
phone interface idea it was like using
the phone almost like a steering wheel
you know to like
yeah do something like we were talking
about how did you do the mobile
uh so it's it's just a mobile website
actually um
and there's not a whole lot to it i can
show a little bit of the code but the
uh
controller
um
is
i'm using a browser if i on the front
end so it looks like node but but it's
actually running on the client
um so this controller clip code uh loads
the device orientation
handler
so um
when the device orientation event fires
it's just taking
that event and
taking the alphabet beta gamma which is
those three degrees of rotation uh and
sending them through socket i o and then
socket i o is just
done broadcasting it back forward to the
uh
you know at any of the viewers so
theoretically you could have a bunch of
uh the viewer open on many different
browser tabs and all of them would stay
in sync
so there's not anything
clever with sessions or whatever
oh yeah
uh so it's only one direction actually
so because i
you know this doesn't have to know about
anything that
the viewer does like this is just
sending events really okay
yeah yeah so right right so so from the
client um i'm listening to device
orientation and sending that as a on the
gyro channel i believe is the
terminology
and then similarly
for drag events so you know
the kind of panning and then the zooming
sending those events through
through the drag channel
and
the node code is actually the
simplest part of this whole thing um it
is just
um
okay so yeah so
when socket io gets a connection um i'm
just wiring up you know this channel
or both those channels and saying
anytime anytime there's events on that
channel just broadcast it so it's it's
just
acting as a connector it's really not
doing doing very much at all
um so yeah then the client receives the
you know gyro events and interprets
those as the rotations and then get the
drag events and interpret those as
as
you know displacement of position
yeah exactly yeah so it's applying that
to
the mesh
which in the viewers
yeah so when when the clock this is the
viewer code now so when it gets a gyro
event
um
yeah it is just holding on to the device
orientation and then the render event
you know with every uh frame
is saying
um
you know okay what should because i it's
not like offsets it's not like you know
i move this
for orientation at least it's absolute
right so i can just
i can just store whatever the rotation
is that that the most recent rotation is
and that's going to be the position of
the
the the rotational
the rotation of the mesh
with the with the drag i am using offset
so you know
it was moved like you know 10 units in
this direction or whatever
um so that i'm just able to store that
position and i don't know there's some
messy code in here that
that does the
yeah the rotation the rotation in here i
think the um
it creates
creates the oil rotation which is those
three angles and then applies that to
the quaternion which is like the vector
yeah so i think with that i'm just
controlling the position of the camera i
think yeah
or it might have been i don't remember
one end up doing like either the camera
or the object itself but
yeah yeah yeah
any other
is this on questions
yeah
so that is a good outro
um
yep that's my name that's my twitters
and that's the repository where you can
find this so thank you very much happy
to talk about afterwards
you